[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in mike florio pro football
talk live co-host football night in
america
more teams who are set at quarterback
are not set at quarterback for the
future
oh more that are but every year now
we're seeing this churn of teams who are
deciding yeah we have a guy who's good
enough but we can do better we want one
of the best guys we're going to upgrade
from the guy we have who's maybe on the
fringes of the top 20 and we're going to
go try to get somebody better whether
it's through the draft get yourself in
position to get one of these rookies
that comes in and takes the league by
storm or make a big play for one of the
big names that's going to be out there
this year whether it's aaron rodgers
russell wilson desean watson so i think
that teams are more willing than ever
before to give up the bird in the hand
even if the bird in the hand
isn't all that bad well i wonder what
the lions do if kenny pickett grades out
as he's the best quarterback and the
lions are on the clock number one pick
you have jared goff but do you pass on
kenny pickett
i think you've
hey look if if pickett is the guy
and the lions have that pick
i think that's what they have to do not
that having matthew stafford for a
decade made much of a difference but
this is a team that is trying to
completely rebuild identity
change culture in a dramatic way it's
not just dan campbell it goes all the
way to chris spielman he's the guy who's
kind of the
overlooked straw that is stirring that
drink the old school mentality that's
where the bite your kneecaps comes from
it doesn't come from campbell it comes
from spielman so goff isn't that guy
goff was the guy that they took on in
order to get two first-round picks and a
third round pick from the rams as part
of the stafford deal goff was the you
get an extra first round or if you take
this guy off of our hands and take his
contract so i i think they have to be
looking quarterback goff is clearly not
the guy and if pickett is pull the
trigger and off you go i wonder mike if
russell wilson and the seahawks maybe
have a formula that's similar to what
the lions and matthew stafford had and
that is
let's just agree to part can you send me
to one of these teams and get the most
in return let's work together on this
and
maybe have something behind the scenes
where it's amicable sort of and you guys
go in your opposite directions what do
you think
well i i agree and i think that russell
has been trying to do that the way that
things got
got kicked up last year in the offseason
he comes on your show and it's obvious
he's not happy at that point his agent
says my client doesn't want to be traded
but if he were to be traded he would
accept the trade to the bears the
cowboys the raiders of the saints i mean
it's obvious where this is going i think
it's premature to start identifying
teams i know there was some reporting
last week to that effect there's a lot
that has to happen before we know where
coaches are going to be where
quarterbacks are or aren't going to be
but i agree with you the time has come
for a big decision to be made in seattle
whether that's we're going to move on
from the coach and bring in somebody
who's hand-picked to make russell happy
or whether it's we're going to keep the
coach and we're going to let russell
move on or both we're just going to hit
the reset button and start over and i
think what happens the next four weeks
dan is going to be a factor in that
because they still have a chance to get
over 500 they have a chance to sneak
into the postseason field much different
vibe if that's the end result of this
season than what it looked like a couple
of weeks ago when they were in crash and
burn territory any games in jeopardy
being postponed
no absolutely not because the league's
not going to do it they're not going to
do it the commissioner said it wednesday
they are not going to postpone these
games and one thing i'm trying to find
out and the league is being very elusive
on this shockingly
what is the minimum number of players
that a team is expected to put in
uniform 48 is the maximum that you can
have on game day you got 69 on the
roster so you already have a 21 person
buffer so when i hear 10 guys on cover
15 guys on covet you got the ability to
call up all of your practice squad guys
you can still get to 48. once you start
getting below 48
45
40
35 where's that number it's almost like
a reverse price is right game where's
that number where the nfl says
it's not enough where the union says
that's not enough
and would they postpone a game if the
browns have fewer than 30 players who
can dress i don't know and the league
won't say and part of me thinks dan that
they've got some double secret procedure
that they would invoke where basically
they can pull guys out of the stands and
put them in uniform to get the games in
because they're getting the games in
that's one thing that's clear they're
not giving up the ticket money they're
not giving up the tv money and dan this
browns raiders game especially
it's one of the nfl network exclusive
games they have a minimum number of
games that have to be exclusive to nfl
network to justify the subscription
rates for cable satellite streaming they
got to have that game on there they are
playing these games the question is how
good will these games be how many guys
will be in uniform
yeah i'm just trying to figure this out
it felt like there was a disconnect with
the nfl and the nfl players association
so
what is the solution you think that
they're gonna is are they able to come
to some kind of agreement that over the
the final month of the regular season
this is what we're going to do when it
comes to covet well they've reached an
agreement on the return to play ability
for a player who is
vaccinated
asymptomatic and positive
what you need to do to come back it's
not as stringent it doesn't take as long
to come back now look i've been saying
for weeks now that if a player is
vaccinated and positive and totally
asymptomatic there's no reason to keep
them from playing we've gotten to the
point in this pandemic where we can
evolve our thinking to a point where we
say
they're not transmitting it on the field
look at all the fans in the stands there
haven't been outbreaks fans are in the
stands and surely plenty of them are
positive and you know how the masks are
worn dipped down over the chin
and it's not a problem it doesn't
transmit in stadiums it doesn't transmit
in domes it's not a problem there and at
some point they need to address that
because the idea that you have
healthy players who just happen to be
positive for this virus who are
vaccinated that you're just not going to
let them play
that that undermines the integrity of
the game how can it not if you're not
going to have the best players available
for reasons unrelated to injury or true
actual illness that's where this needs
to move in 2022
i doubt that it gets there this year but
that's where this has to go because we
know this thing isn't going anywhere
mike florio pro football talk live
co-host uh who would get a head coaching
job sooner urban meyer john
gruden
which league
nsfl is coming back
uh
yeah look i i think that that
it'd be easier for urban meyer just
because he didn't leave with that same
stain
of the
language in the emails that gruden had
to walk out the door basically tattooed
to his resume forever meyer still denies
for example kicking
kicker josh lambo he denies getting into
a heated argument with marvin jones he
denies calling his assistant coach his
loser so it's harder to wrap your hands
around one thing that urban meyer did
that makes him
permanently and forever toxic and he's
got
i'm
look he deserved to be fired he never
should have been an nfl head coach but
he's one of the great college coaches of
all time and there's a lot of college
programs out there and
uh
there's going to be somebody
that's thinking hey we may get this guy
right place right time and he comes in
for a final act of his career of
redemption that makes us a hell of a lot
of money along the way this just in that
taylor heinecke and kyle allen now on
the covet list so i guess it's gay uh
garrett gilbert who's going to be pl
this is why that point spread has gone
from four to ten against the eagles
this is what you're gonna have on
national tv kyle shermer is another
quarterback that they have
garrett gilbert one of the many backup
quarterbacks out there where you can
interchange the last name in the first
name and it all makes sense and and when
you're down to that level of quarterback
you have a problem but it
dan the league doesn't care they don't
care that it's going to be a debacle of
a game they don't care that it's going
to be fatal potentially to washington's
playoff hopes they're not going to move
that game they're not going to do
anything to jeopardize the flow of cash
into the coffers it's that simple and
and it's it's unfortunate
but
that that's their current attitude and
approach and it just doesn't fit with
the current state of the pandemic where
this latest variant apparently is
ridiculously contagious but also
ron rivera said today on radio and dc
that 80 percent of his guys who are
positive have no symptoms at all
is there any update on desean watson
oh well there is and i'm glad you asked
about him because he's been forgotten
since the trade deadline came and went
they're expecting some sort of a
resolution to the grand jury proceeding
by the end of january and that kind of
fits with the nfl's offseason timeline
although the quarterback carousel gets
started mid to late january we saw it
last year with matthew stafford teams
are going to start making decisions it
could be misdemeanor charges that
ultimately are filed against deshaun
watson not felonies which would be a
difference from the league's standpoint
but as to the civil lawsuits i was told
last night and this is how close
that
the miami dolphins came to getting to
sean watson because the dolphins wanted
these civil lawsuits to be resolved
there are 22 of them 18 of the
plaintiffs were ready to go
four of them held out and that's what
derailed the settlements and that's what
derailed the trade to miami miami wanted
them all gone they weren't content to
have 18 gone and four left they wanted
them all gone if those last four had
come around he'd be a dolphin right now
but is tua playing himself into
that franchise quarterback role here
well tua did what he needed to do he was
upset about the ongoing distraction and
the talk and the chatter and just it
wouldn't go away well once the trade
deadline went away then the talk ended
and tua has strung one win after another
together and now they're gonna have a
tougher decision to make you know his
durability is what concerns me over the
long haul but he's playing better he did
what he needed to do you know what if
you don't like the fact that they're
talking about desean watson go out there
and be desean watson be better than
deshawn watson that's the tom brady
attitude get a chip on your shoulder and
stick up your ass and go out there and
play better and make them
unable to consider bringing in a better
quarterback because you are the better
quarterback
uh the mothership reported that it's uh
unlikely according to sources diana
rossini saying this that uh your good
buddy aaron rodgers won't be back with
the packers
um i don't know what that means that
even if he wins the super bowl that he's
not coming back
um is this roger's decision packers
decision mutual decision any decision at
all mike i mean we entered the season as
if it was his last year yeah
we we've known this it's going to take
something big to reverse it and like
what
well i i i really do
can you if you are aaron rodgers and you
are extremely sensitive about how you're
perceived by the fan base
can you
win a super bowl
and say see you later maybe you can
maybe maybe they're fine with it hey
thank you you gave us one on the way out
the door via condios and just don't go
play for another team in our division or
in our conference i i just think that
just like with russell wilson the end
result to this year
is going to be a factor in whether or
not it continues now we know next year
will be the last year because of his
contract because he becomes a free agent
after 2022 but we went into this year
assuming that this is it and
you know the the whole the vaccine thing
and i've been immunized in the disrupt
but they're still really good
and they got a glimpse of jordan love
and
i i'd want to keep aaron rodgers i'd
want to find a way to make him happy and
keep him around i mean
for all the headaches that he brings
he's still one of the best quarterbacks
in the nfl why would you want to move on
from him why would you not want to do
everything you could to convince him to
stick around why would you want to leave
that division
if you're aaron rodgers
right
i mean well minnesota is stuck in
neutral
the bears aren't good the lions aren't
good
and
you know do i i think he ends up in
denver you know i think they've geared
up for this and and maybe that's where
you know he wants to go
but it feels like you're gonna have
desean watson russell wilson and aaron
rodgers and
you know those are pretty good prizes if
you don't get one you get another one
there but i i just feel like rogers is
going to be a good soldier do everything
you ask me to do
and uh you know remember you had guys
who cover the packers on a daily basis
rob demotsky covers them for the
mothership said 5 chance he was coming
back and i went
he's coming back
the question is how long does he stay
and i think we were in agreement he was
going to be there one year no matter
what happens this year
let's not rule out this possibility dan
that we're being grifted by aaron
rodgers that he just wants to be the
topic of conversation that he wants us
to be talking about him that he wants to
be the center of attention
and maybe he ultimately does come back
to the packers next year okay and if so
mission accomplished hang the banner
behind george w bush mission
accomplished really and truthfully he is
the center of attention we talk about
him all the time i mean look at his toe
injury he's pissed off because people on
the coaching staff supposedly are
telling people he's showing the damn
thing on camera
every time he talks he's talking about
his toe injury hey everybody i have a
broken toe he's almost as bad as ben
roethlisberger and speaking of
rothersburg i'm intrigued by the
steelers as a destination for rogers
because why would you go to denver
didn't you watch the game last night
they got patrick mahomes and justin
herbert in that division but but boy the
idea of aaron rodgers just about a
hundred miles up the road for me i could
go up and have her permanent sandwich
with him once a week
because you two are buddies buddies yeah
you know what's funny dan he and i have
a lot more in common than he would ever
admit i i understand him because i'm a
lot like him hopefully well not not in
the football way
and not necessarily in the good
personality trait way so but i
understand you're both know-it-alls
you're both know-it-alls exactly exactly
uh both married you want to see my toe
yes
you both love to talk about aaron
rodgers
yes yeah uh good for business oh my god
you should have seen our numbers for
november he's great for business aaron i
said i said during the height of the
whole i'm immunized and all that other
stuff i hope he never retires i hope he
stays with the packers until he's 60. i
hope it's every year this drama he's
great for business
thank you mike great to talk to you
all right you too buddy that's mike
florio he's not afraid pro football talk
live co-host and of course contributor
to football night in america